Pete's power science awesome food
tonight Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the
movie so if you're alive at all if you
have a pulse whatsoever you know what
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles are
what you might not know is there was a
time when the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles just ruled all they conquered
the world of entertainment and toys and
in this golden age of life they made a
couple movies not that they made a third
one ever
they didn't that does not count now I
lived for the Ninja Turtles as a kid
when I was younger I remember like in
the second Ninja Turtles movie more than
the first one but now that I'm an adult
and I watched the first one just the
other day I gotta say I like this one
more now it's not meant for my age
demographic now if you weren't into the
Ninja Turtles when you were younger and
you're some 20-something year old who's
watching this review and you end up
going and watching the Ninja Turtles
movie you can't just be like Ninja
Turtle sucks you gotta look at it for
what it is it's meant for younger human
beings and is it better than most kids
movies these days yeah like a million
times yeah this movie is great for kids
and it actually has a lot in there for
adults too surprisingly I mean you can
see it as shredders building up his Foot
Clan to take over New York City with
crime or you can see the themes about
family in the movie kids feeling
rejected shredder preying on that to get
what he wants and the Ninja Turtles
finding out about family as one of their
owns out of commission good stuff good
themes not too preachy and Ninja
badassery with turtles now straight up
elias koteas as Casey Jones is pretty
much awesome in its own awesomeness
realm of Awesome he's that sarcastic
character that makes the movie a little
more enjoyable especially for adults
kids they're drawn to one of the four
turtles adults we love Casey Jones and
there are jokes in this movie that went
over my head as a kid when I watched it
the other day I was like holy crap they
just said that like they ride into the
city in the back of a pickup truck
they're like sneaking into the city all
the Turtles jump out in Raphael goes now
I know what it's like to travel without
a green card I mean I was like holy crap
as an immigrant joke that is awesome
missed that when I was younger I mean
there's the prospect of four turtles on
a rat mutating into intelligent beings
that learn ninjutsu realistic no but
it's a good family movie with some
kickass ninja turtles that is absolutely
enjoyable for kids and surprisingly
enjoyable for adults Jeremy Jones
promoting the family hour now there are
some things that I remember watching and
loving as a kid then I watch them
now years later and they do not stand
the test of time like not at all
but the Ninja Turtles movie does to a
surprising degree but I got to say that
scene with Raphael just freaks out and
yells that used to freak me out as a kid
and now I have it as my ringtone morbid
yeah but you know so kids will find this
movie
ninja tacular and adults will find this
movie has a good time no alcohol
required unless you're an elitist
bastard that just not to a Duvall's
Ninja Turtles good then surprisingly
good now but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more than
click right here to see more
[Music]